As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. I'm so happy to be able to
talk to you today. [music]
And mashallah, my brother, our Sheikh
Ali Hamuda, is doing a great job. Waqf
Forever is [music] a very, very uh
beautiful cause because the reward of
what you give is not just
>> [music]
>> at the moment of giving, but rather, it
is prolonged for a very, very long time,
>> [music]
>> and it lasts for as long as that waqf
continues to generate to generate some
form of [music] benefit. So, I highly
recommend Waqf Forever. As an ambassador
of Abdullah Aid, I know the the uh
partnership that we have is amazing.
>> [music]
>> And uh not many people understand the
concept of waqf, yet the reward is far
greater through the waqf. So, inshallah,
if you can support Waqf Forever,
uh it will be really, really amazing and
very, very rewarding.
So, some people think that the woman
wear the hijab because men are animals.
That's not correct. Because God doesn't
tell him, because we as men, Allah tells
us in the Quran, "Tell Muslim men and
Muslim I came to Islam 13 years ago. So,
God tells me
to not look at woman in a bad way. Why?
Because it's not woman's fault. You
can't blame a woman. You can't say men
are animals. We don't believe in this
our religion. We believe men and women
have to do their part. So, as a man, if
I am walking and I see somebody dressed
in a mini skirt or she wear niqab, I
don't look. It doesn't matter how she's
dressed. So, because why? In today's
time, a lot of women are sexually
objectified in the West. For example,
you have an advertisement about a
chocolate and there's a naked woman.
What's a woman got to do with the
chocolate? So, because Islam has come to
say no, a woman is a human being. You as
a human like you woman, you have more to
offer than your body parts. That's why
Islam is very against the sexual
objectification of woman. You know, and
Islam is come the symbol the hijab is is
a symbol to show that she's a Muslim
woman. And of course there's an element
for example because we as men, we are
visual creatures. Yeah, because as men
we fall for what we see. With you guys
you fall for what you hear. You're more
emotional if a man comes and says, "Oh,
you're beautiful. You are like this.
You're like, okay, he maybe loves me."
But so what the hijab does is it
protects you to an extent against men
who have the wrong intentions. That's
why in Islam we don't believe What's
your name? Nina. Nina and? Yula.
Yula. Nice name. Are they Dutch names?
Yes. That's good. My name is Ali. So in
Islam that's why we don't believe in
dating outside of marriage. Because
dating outside of marriage, what
feminism has done, it tells you the
sexual liberation.
That means go do you, sleep around with
everyone. But what that does is it
really harms a woman. Because the way
God has created you, you are very
delicate. Yes, and you can be vulnerable
as well. So when a man takes advantage
of that, so if a man is interested in
you, he's like, "Okay, I'm going to tell
her what she wants to hear."
"I love you. You're the one." Blah blah
blah. And you feel, "Okay, you know
what? Yeah, maybe he loves me."
But can it be that he wants you for the
wrong intentions? It can. Good. So how
does Islam protect you?
Number one, what it does is it says
that, for example, if I am interested in
a woman, I have to speak to her father.
Oh, yeah. Why? Because your dad is a man
and a man knows a man.
So when he sees me and he meets me, he
can look at me and think, "Okay, what's
So what's he about?" Number two, if I'm
getting to know you for marriage, and I
know your dad is in the picture, I'm a
little bit scared now. Because I know if
I treat you wrong, I have to deal with
him.
Number two. So that's number one, your
father or your brother, yeah? Number
two, is something called a dowry. Do you
know what a dowry is?
So it's a gift that's given. So for
example, in Islam, a woman in Islam has
a right of dowry. For example, the man
that wants to marry you, you can say to
him, "I want you to buy me a car. That's
my dowry." Or it's up to you. You can
say I want a ring. I want 5,000 euros. I
want um you take me on holiday. That is
your right. So so yeah yeah. And you
know a lot of people don't know that.
You know why? Because it protects you
against um you know, deadbeat men. Okay,
good. Cuz these men who just want to go
and sleep around some says no. You have
to meet the father. Number two, give
dowry. Because if a man has bad
intentions, you know,
yes. Not only that, why would they pay
5,000 euros? If I want something else, I
can go somewhere else. Do you get what
I'm trying to say? So what that does is
it's protects you. Because we believe in
Islam, you are the price.
Do you get it? We don't believe in this
red pill. That man is a price. No, in
Islam the woman is the price. That's why
he he has to speak to your father. He
has to give you dowry. Then he has to do
a wedding. So what's the wedding for? So
it's not secret. Everybody knows this
man married Nina. Nina and whoever this
person is, they are married. The
community know. So he can't do dirty
stuff.
And lastly sister Nina is that when you
married as a Muslim man, the man has to
pay for everything. There is no 50/50.
We don't believe in this egalitarian
life cuz you have to be looked after. If
you become pregnant, you're vulnerable.
So your husband has to take care of you.
Electric, gas, bill, insurance. He has
to pay for everything. Even if you are a
millionaire,
he doesn't need to pay one penny.
You don't need to pay one penny unless
you choose to. If you say, "You know
what? I feel sorry for him. Let me give
him some money." But your money is your
money.
However, the man also has authority. We
believe in hierarchy. So we believe the
man is the leader of the house. He gives
direction. Why? Because women are a bit
more emotional. That's natural. That's
how you're created. We're a bit more
logical. So because of that, the man is
the leader of the house and you have
trust in your husband, you know, and you
know that he does the right decisions.
But Islam is made this to protect
society and to protect your heart
against heartache. Because when you go
into a relationship, you fall in love
with a man, he treats you wrong,
and then you're left with heartbreak. So
Islam puts these things in place so it
protects you. And it also protects him
as well. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. I didn't know
that. Yeah, exactly. That's why I was
That's why I was explaining cuz a lot of
people they don't know like, "Oh, Islam
oppresses women." Islam gave the rights
to a woman
1,400 years ago. The right to work, the
right to own property, the right to you
like you know like for example,
let's say my wife. My wife does not need
to take my surname. No. But you do. Like
you you you take your husband's surname.
In Islam, no. No. Yeah, no. No. You're
not allowed to cuz she's not my
property. Oh. She does not take my
surname. I have to pay for everything.
She has a right to work. She has to
right to study. All of these rights are
given to her long before feminism was
given. Yeah, yeah. A lot of people don't
know this. Exactly. Exactly. A lot of
people don't know. But yeah, any
questions for me
Nina and Ula. Ula. Ula. What is that
Nuna? Ula. Ula. What does that mean? Is
there a meaning to it? Ula and Nina, is
there
Not that I know of. No problem. Any
questions for me? Anything you didn't
know I can answer.
No, we don't. Fantastic. It was really
nice talking to you guys. Can I give you
guys a free Quran or Oh, yes. It's okay.
Would you like one? Yeah. Sure. Well,
you Ula.
Are you guys sisters or friends? Nieces.
Nieces. Fantastic. Okay, I'll give you
one.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Thank
you so much. Thank you. Is this Is this
uh Grandfather. No, no. This is your
brother. He's a young man. No. Yes. Yes.
Look at him. He's strong man. I'm 25. Of
course. No, you look younger than me.
20. I 25 by 25. No, I am.
>> [laughter]
>> You handsome man. Fantastic. Look after
yourself. Thank you. Look after
grandfather. And in in sorry, in Islam,
looking after grandparents and mother
and father is very important. Thank you.
Look after them well. Hey,
come on. Fantastic. Fantastic. Lovely
family there. Lovely family there.
Alhamdulillah.